how is thor's long journey led him to
lose his avengers endgame weight in thor
love and thunder and how did that weight
signify his mental state keep watching
for a full breakdown to the surprise of
marvel cinematic universe fans around
the world thor gained a significant
amount of weight in avengers endgame the
character's grief and depression are
pivotal points in the movie providing a
look into his mental state in the long
aftermath of the avengers defeat at
thanos hands while the avengers do
reverse the effects of the blip and
restore the universe as they knew it at
the end of avengers end game thor does
not magically return to his prime
fighting weight he remains his new size
when he sets off into space with the
guardians of the galaxy and names the
valkyrie the ruler of new asgard on
earth the new teaser trailer for
director taika watiti's thor love and
thunder shows that thor loses the weight
in what audiences can only hope winds up
as a funny training montage in line with
the trailer's 80s era music while the
trailer does not reveal much it seems
that thor will return to full power in
the new movie despite the seemingly
endless discussion that his post-blip
physique inspired it looks like the
self-proclaimed strongest avenger will
take steps to slim down strongest
avenger access denied
strongest avenger access denied
to quickly recap thor's journey over the
past few movies he and the asgardians
had just lost their home in thor
ragnarok when thanos attacks the
survivors kills loki and halves asgard's
population an enraged thor demonstrates
just how powerful he really is
throughout avengers infinity war when he
helps create stormbreaker and aids the
earthbound avengers in wakanda the god
of thunder nearly kills thanos at the
height of his power but a merely wounded
thanos is able to snap away half of all
life and escape when the avengers
regroup and capture thanos in avengers
end game thor can't control his rage and
lops off the mad titan's head five years
later thor has sunk into a deep
depression that has separated him from
the rest of his new asgard community he
takes the avengers failure personally
spending his time drinking away his
sorrows and playing fortnite with cork
thor seems to be trapped in
psychological angst over the events of
the recent past when rocket and bruce
banner visit him he threatens bruce just
for mentioning thanos's name
um yeah we don't actually say that name
in here thor's insecurities and
depression play a significant role in
his and rocket's time travel mission to
asgard in 2013. rocket even has to
remind thor that he isn't the only
avenger who lost people in the blip or
who feels personal responsibility for
losing to thanos it's not until he
speaks with his mother frigga that he
starts to believe in himself when he
realizes he can still summon mjolnir
even in this new timeline he finally
understands that he's still worthy of
his powers regardless of what he's done
what's happened to him or what he looks
like when the avengers meet back up
after their time travel missions thor
immediately volunteers to reverse the
blip with the new infinity gauntlet but
the rest of the team refuses to let him
wield the gauntlet because he's so
emotional
let me do something good
while thor doesn't personally kill
thanos from 2014 they meet at the climax
of avengers end game his actions prove
indispensable in saving the half of the
universe wiped out five years previously
at the end of the movie thor sets off
with the guardians of the galaxy to find
a new purpose in life in the new teaser
trailer for thor love and thunder thor
describes himself as a symbol of peace
on his journey to find himself in a
post-blip universe these hands were once
used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
we see a humorous shot of him performing
crossfit style battle rope exercises
with giant chains while wearing a hat
that reads strongest avenger in the next
shot thor takes off his coat revealing
that he's lost all of his post-blip
weight even after his physical
transformation it seems thor may avoid
physical conflict for at least the early
parts of thor love and thunder the
film's teaser trailer shows him walking
away from a battle alongside the
guardians of the galaxy he even claims
that he's done living as a superhero and
travels the galaxy with korg until the
movie's main conflict takes shape
obviously thor will return to battle at
some point in the new movie this time
with jane foster at his side as the
mighty thor but audiences have yet to
see how gore the god butcher will draw
him out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you